what i want to do in this video is prove
to ourselves that vertical angles really
are equal to each other their measures
are really equal to each other so let's
say i have a line here and let's say
that i have another line over there and
let's call this this point a let's call
this point b
point c
let's call this d and let's call this
right over e and so i'm just going to
pick an arbitrary angle over here let's
say angle c b
what is this cbe looks like an f this is
angle cbe what i what i want to do is if
i can prove that angle cbe is always
going to be equal to its vertical angle
so angle dba then i've proved that
vertical angles are always going to be
equal because this is just a
generalizable case right over here so
what i want to prove
what i want to prove here
is angle
c
b
e
is equal to i could say the measure of
angle cbe you'll see it different ways
actually this time let me write it
without measure so that you get used to
the different notations i'll just say
proof angle cbe is equal to angle dba is
equal to angle
equal to angle dba so the first thing we
know
the first thing we know so what do we
we know that angle cbe and we know that
angle dbc are are supplementary they are
adjacent angles and their outer sides of
both angles form a straight angle over
here so we know that angle c
b e
and angle so this is c b e and angle dbc
and angle d b c
are supplementary i'll just write sup
for that they're supplementary which
means that angle c b e
plus angle d
b c is equal to 180 degrees
fair enough we also know so let me see
this is cb this is what we care about
and we want to prove that this is equal
to that we also know that angle dba
we know this is dba right over here we
also know that angle
dba
and angle
dbc
and angle d
bc are supplementary this angle and this
angle are supplementary their outer
sides form a straight angle they are
adjacent so they are supplementary which
tells us that angle dba
this angle right over here
plus angle d
c
this angle over here is going to be
equal to
180 degrees
now from this
from this top one
this top statement over here we can
subtract angle dbc from both sides
and we get angle c
b e
is equal to 180 degrees minus angle dbc
that's this information right over here
i just put the angle dbc on the right
side or i subtracted it from both sides
of the equation
and
this right over here if i do the exact
same thing subtract angle dbc from both
sides of the equation i get angle d
b a is equal to 180 degrees let me
scroll over to the right a little bit is
equal to 180 degrees minus angle
dbc
so clearly angle cbe is equal to 180
degrees minus angle dbc angle dba is
equal to 180 degrees minus angle dbc so
they are equal to each other they are
both equal to the same thing so we get
which is what we wanted to get angle c
b e is equal to
angle d
b a angle c b e which is this angle
right over here is equal to angle d b a
and sometimes you might see that shown
like this so angle c b e that's its
measure and you'd say that this measure
right over here is the exact same amount
and we have other vertical angles
whatever this measure is and sometimes
you'll see it with a double line like
that that you could say that that is
going to be the same as whatever this
angle right over here is you'll see it
written like that sometimes i like to
use colors but not all books have the
luxury of colors or sometimes you'll
even see it written like this to show
that they're the same angle this angle
and this angle and show that these are
different sometimes they'll say that
they're the same in this way this vertic
this angle is equal to this vertical
angle is equal to its its vertical angle
right over here and this angle is equal
to this angle that's opposite the
intersection right over here
but we've proved it for the general case
because all i did here is i just did two
general intersecting lines i picked a
random angle and then i proved that it's
equal to the angle that is vertical to
it